the jurogan experience
but yeah these these guys um
i attempted for about 10 years through
my then organization quilliam
to attempt to pretty much has happened
to me on the islamist side to attempt to
try and soften some of that hard edge of
the war how was that met with bush
he was charming but of course it wasn't
ever going to be bush it was going to be
the people around him right what was his
perspective on what you're saying the
last two years of the bush presidency i
think they really began getting to grips
with some of this
and again that's not a popular thing to
say and i remember the time is that
those last two years they began
realizing that this has to be more of an
ideological and intellectual
conversation and not a physical war you
can't win
right right in this war until there was
no way anyone was going to win and so
they were stuck in this situation was
many years deep into the war and
realizing that they had done everything
that they were trying to avoid we had
had that one desert storm war and i
think people had come under the
impression that if we were to invade a
country it would be very quick and very
easy yeah we had this very
american-centric
idea of what would go on in a war and
because of that it made us so much more
willing to enter into war it's insane
it's insane if a foreign army occupied
america would you just sit back and let
them stay here for ten i mean come on no
man worth his salt is going to sit there
and watch a foreign army in there if
anyone invaded britain i'd be the first
to say sign me up where do i join no one
is just going to let foreign troops in
their land right so but this madness was
brought about because back in those days
bush didn't even know the difference
between sunni and shia muslims
right that it was just pure ignorance
that the the foreign policy
neoconservative machine was hoodwinked
by this guy called celebi in iraq who
convinced them that if you invade
everything's gonna be hunky-dory iraq is
gonna blossom into this democracy all
that ended up happening is sixty percent
of iraq was shia you end up creating a
satellite of sphere of influence for
iran
because iran is his shia origin country
and it ended up having this
disproportionate influence in iraq as a
result
and you end up with a situation today i
mean it's a mess when you think back to
this man trying to convince the bush
administration that everything was going
to be fine it was going to blossom into
a democracy
what do you think was his motivation do
you think ultimately he knew that the
shia and the sunni would
go to battle and there would be a
massive conflict and that it would
destabilize the region do you think he
was aware of that or do you think they
were operating on ignorance or do you
think they were operating under this
premise that they were going to get to
control the natural resources and it was
worth it financially and they would sort
it all out
well you know
individual intentions aside if you look
to cheney if you look to rumsfeld and if
you looked at this guy challenging he
was from the iraqi national congress
and if you look at everything that
happened since then and the behavior in
iraq and and beyond
it's definitely not
about bringing democracy now the jew is
out for me is it oil is it
natural resources is it strategic
positioning um
it's definitely not what the reason that
we were told and it certainly wasn't
weapons of mass destruction that was all
built on a lie and that's also come out
since
uh do you think they knew about the lie
for sure
how many people do you think knew about
like when they were broadcasting in on
cnn weapons of mass destruction we have
to invade iraq
who do you think knew i mean that was
nice remember
yes i'm quite sure he knew he was
speaking [ __ ] god that's so hard to
believe yeah it's so hard to believe
because he's he's so admired
and you know when you when you have an
example of a man who is a distinguished
military career and then goes on to be a
distinguished politician he's one of the
best examples we've ever had but you
remember he was opposed to it for a long
time yes and then he gave that one
speech i think it was at the u.n yes and
i think that's the point that he he knew
what was going he was opposed to it he
didn't want to follow this he had a vial
of something and then somebody gave him
something and then he said all right you
know and and i think when he did that
that speech yeah i think he knew in his
heart something's not right what was the
vial what did he have i can't remember
but it was used as evidence right yes
what we've had since in the uk is an
inquiry and they found that tony blair
pretty much you know they all knew that
something wasn't right with this
intelligence they were given and this 15
minutes thing it just wasn't right you
know and the guy the guy that exposed it
one of our scientists 15 minutes thing
that saddam can can uh strike within 15
minutes of it yeah yeah and there's a
guy who on particular with the weapons
of mass destruction now again caveat
saddam is no picnic right yeah i mean
the man has gassed his own people he he
was he's the iraqi equivalent of mubarak
that did what he did to us in egypt and
his sons were the most evil i mean look
again people think i'm going to defend
this isn't about defending it this is
true the first
the first death in our organization my
former group was in iraq one of our
members was tortured to death by saddam
we were attempting to overthrow saddam
too right so this is no favoritism to
saddam hussein coming from me what i'm
saying is that you don't go in
into war based on a lie and this guy
called dr kelly in the uk he was the
scientist uh from our whatever our
defense sector who exposed this lie he
turned out dead a couple of weeks later
no one knows what happened to him he's
dead so it's just all weird right but
looking died of what they found him dead
in his car
i think it's officially suicide whatever
who knows yeah i mean i don't know was
epstein's suicidal
i say no
it doesn't look like it does it i get
very uncomfortable when people say he
did commit suicide it's a bit weird
isn't it well i started asking them
questions like why do you think that
like did you look at the autopsy did you
ever hear michael baden speak about it
where he talks about like ligature marks
at the bottom of his neck which indicate
he was strangled yeah do you did you
hear about the bro breaking broken bones
rather in his neck yeah like that don't
exist
normally when people hang themselves
they usually are only from someone being
strangled yeah there's a desire the
camera thing
the security guard's conveniently
sleeping like there's so much
it's all strange but it's in front of
everybody's face watch me pull a rabbit
out of my hat
and you're like holy [ __ ] if the lie is
big enough right this is a good one
though i mean it's it's quite
extraordinary that they were to pull
that off they were able to pull that off
in front of everyone's eyes well i mean
i don't know if they've pulled it off
i'm not so sure people deep down really
really truly believe that that's i mean
everyone i think realizes more than
meets the eye with that
yeah i think so people don't want to
speak about it but it's gone on long
enough that i think it's going to be a
part of the past yeah and people are
just going to go what happened to him
who knows what happened to kennedy who
knows like i just said with dr kelly
right yes who knows who knows but what
we have learned from that is
that it's easy to manufacture
um
consent around something that isn't true
for foreign policy purposes it was done
with iraq and my whole thing was
how do we stop that happening again
right that's what i was trying to do
with with bush
with all of them when but when you're
way through to cameron what what kind of
dialogue did you have with bush in terms
of like trying to convince him to take a
different approach
well he so as i say in his last two
years they were listening so i met with
um
secretary chertoff who founded the
homeland security
he used to be a judge
and
we would work very closely with homeland
security
and that entire group
and what happened was if you recall so
those last two years then obama got
elected and as always just as we felt we
will make beginning to make progress i
mean one of my long my bug bears has
long been we have to shut guantanamo bay
down this idea that that we can
throw people in jail for years and years
and years over decades with no charge
right it started with jihadi prisoners
you moved to syria it moved from jihadi
prisoners to their wives and their
children now
so there's just been a jailbreak in
syria and isis attempted jailbreak
now there's a bit there's a bit of
detail to that story that's more
interesting than the fact that isis in
the first organized attack
for many years since the fall of their
so-called islamic state
um have demonstrated that they've
regrouped because they had a full
frontal assault on this jail
but that's not what interests me and i
think that the
kurdish forces have retaken it just
yesterday what interests me is the
detail in this in this little um story
and that is that it turns out that there
were hundreds of children in this jail
children born to isis fighters who
nobody wanted to take care of so they
threw them in this adult jihadi prison
hundreds of children some of whom died
in this attempted jailbreak so we've
gone from and this is where when the
overton window shifts in that way when
you think our bush's years if only our
value system has shifted so much to a
point we are now
living with this idea that our states
and our allies can throw children in
jail for years with some of the most
dangerous people on the planet and it
went from
giardi's in guantanamo to in syria now
to their wives and children including by
the way western citizens so this
jailbreak some of the kids that were
killed 16 year olds 17 year olds uh
western citizens australians you know
and others american as an american kid
in the times newspaper
and why were there in the prison because
they were taken there as kids
by their jihadi parents
and nobody wants to do no western
government credit to america under trump
you guys took back all your foreign
foreign fighters from isis
britain hasn't done so nor have most
europeans took back all our foreign
fighters who were americans who went to
join isis yeah
they're now back in the yeah they're
back and you know you bring them back
and if there's a crime to answer for you
put them on trial but what you haven't
done what america hasn't done is say you
know what i don't give a damn they might
be american but they can stay in syria
and even if they're sentenced in syria
say they finish their time where do they
go
right so that's what's happened is
nobody so there's camps there are entire
camps they're just internship camps
concentration camps or intern camps like
alhaul campbell hall in syria where
there's
women and children
kids from babies and they're growing up
and they're having they're giving birth
in these prisons and they're just no
one's charged them or convicted them of
anything so they're essentially being
raised in these prisons they are born
and raised in prisons jesus christ now
you go from guantanamo to that and i'm
going to bring you to another stage
right we're talking about the overton
window of acceptability shifting we've
got a home secretary in the uk right now
called pretty patel
she then suggested
that what do you do with um these boat
people that come over from france and
they're trying to cross the english
channel undocumented migrants they're
landing in britain what do you do with
them she said i know what we can do with
them arrest them
and then put them in a camp in rwanda so
you've gone from
we've gone from
arbitrarily interning jihadis to
arbitrarily interning their wives and
their children to now arbitrarily
interning anyone who's undocumented in
these camps that's not the kind of world
i want to see going forward
it's like that movie elysium right yes
that's not the kind of world i want to
see going forward so this is the kind of
thing that i was upset with in that
machine and i'm trying to work in the
machine to say
what you guys are doing is making the
problem worse with this kind of behavior
power brute force does not fix your
problems and these conversations with
bush in particular like what was that
like how did he respond to this so so
bush was one meeting and after that one
meeting i was able to speak to the
administration and as i say so for the
last two years i felt we felt we were
beginning to make progress
obama gets in
and then they want to reinvent the will
and a lot of people when they look at
obama they think a great president again
i'm not going to mince my words and i
don't want anyone to say i see magic is
this or that guys i'm you'll understand
i didn't even come from this system i
wanted to overthrow the whole thing
obama and bush together i was
anti-democracy full stop so this is not
about me supporting bush supposing obama
supporting trump supporting anyone i'm
looking at this from the outside and
seeing what's going wrong vis-a-vis this
specific debate yeah
and speaking objectively about it
regardless of whether you're left-wing
or right-wing so obama comes in
and this man launches more drone strikes
than bush
has a kill list which bush never had
that is unaccountable that kill list he
made including american citizens was not
accountable to congress
so on the
on the physical war side he basically
did even more than bush did with his
assassinations with his um nsa spying
uh with his um
military approach to solving problems
with his drones more drone strikes than
bush ever conducted he just ratcheted up
the military side of this and uh we were
then when obama became president my work
was for a long time ostracized from the
obama administration because of this
point and then where he should have done
something like the rise of isis
completely useless so your work was
ostracized because you were working
towards peace and a less brutal approach
and he was conducting drone strikes and
they didn't want to hear surveillance
they just didn't want to hear they want
to hear it and they but they knew your
position and
did you eventually get to meet with him
not him not him wow i met i've met i met
hillary clinton i met madden albright
but i didn't meet obama did you ever
meet anybody they smell like sulfur
what any of those people
feel like they're evil this is an evil
person this is for sure from straight
from hell so um
anyway
just [ __ ] right now
but you met hillary clinton you met
george bush who else did you meet inside
the organization
on the u.s side um
madeleine albright secretary chertoff
when he was head of the homeland
security department was any one group or
one
administration more open to your ideas
well the same thing happened it's
usually the case right it takes six
years last two years of the obama
administration like the last two years
of bush they began listening to us
and then of course biden sorry trump
comes in